encore plus haut peut-être pas mais
encore plus beau ici la hausse à 360
degrés c'est ce que propose le belvédère
de la roche merveilleuse qui surplombe
le cirque
si l'os qui voit plus de cinq cent mille
visiteurs par an proposent désormais un
aménagement plus sécurisé aux promeneurs
point d'orgue de ce réaménagement
l'accès au belvédère avec à l'entrée la
légende de la roche merveilleuse les
femmes venaient se frotter leurs ventres
pour pour être fertile des c'était de
proposer donc une forme de scénographie
à travers un fil conducteur une
thématique donc la géographie physique
et humaine l'histoire et les légendes
donc de cilaos et donc on a proposé
trois médias d'interprétation pour
valoriser en fait et permettre aux
visiteurs à travers une approche
émotionnelle et qui suscite l'émotion
d'apprécier le site et de vouloir aussi
le préserver tout le long de la montée
des garde-corps et une main courante
outre de sécuriser le site permet
également d'aidé à l'accès au belvédère
pourtant environ une douzaine d'ouvriers
plus l'association et moi mais environ
un mois
une nuit à travailler là dessus en
comptant toutes ride équipe avec le
conseil général et les ingénieux
louannec au sommet un tableau
d'interprétation permet d'obtenir des
informations
le visiteur de son poste d'observation
apprend l'histoire de cilaos
c'est un atout très important pour
cilaos pour la roche merveilleuse comme
parce que les gens tous les gens qui
viennent à cilaos viennent sur ceux ci
c'est vrai quand ils verront les
aménagements qui ont été apportées par
ce que si on vient on y revient à chaque
fois combien tu as à cilaos on vient sur
ceux ci
et c'est vrai que pour nous c'est très
important d'apporter de la qualité sur
ces espaces publics une réhabilitation
qui fait écho à une volonté certaine du
conseil départemental de redonner une
nouvelle couleur à ce site très
fréquenté le silo rouge par veilleux
c'est l'un des sites principaux du
cirque de cilaos qui comme d'autres
sites soit un petit peu vieilli il
fallait donc le réaménager donc nous
avons construit un projet avec l'aide du
département c'était un projet
partenarial qui avait plusieurs
objectifs d'abord l'adapter aux
nouvelles conditions je dirais sociale
des promeneurs prend en compte une
meilleure accessibilité avec une
accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite prendre en compte
également la fonctionnalité du site
on a pris en compte le fait que des cars
pouvait arriver jusqu'ici et qu'il
fallait leur donner l'occasion de
stationner de déposer légende pouvoir
faire demi-tour facilement outre
l'aménagement du belvédère le site de la
roche merveilleuse propose désormais des
espaces d'accueil pour les familles
réunionnaises et les traditionnel pique
nique du dimanche
kiosque accès aux personnes à mobilité
réduite l'espace s'offrent à la balade
mais également aux grandes tables et
animée
l'objectif principal c'était l'accueil
du public l'interprétation est l'accueil
des personnes à mobilité réduite
donc on a revu tout l'aménagement du
site en recréant des nouveaux kiosques
en recréant des nouveaux hors d'accueil
avec des places à feu des hommes pour
poser les mares mais les bancs des
fauteuils on her prévu tous ces
aménagements
on a prévu une zone pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
les équipes de loi n'est font fabriquer
monter tous les garde-corps envoyé
l'immobilier de pique nique qu'ils
s'agissent des kiosques ou encore des
tables il ne reste plus désormais qu'à
sortir les marmites ou de s'offrir cette
vue magnifique sur les cirques pitons
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco